[موسيقى]
مساء الخير مشاهدي العربيه واهلا بكم الى
التاسعه مع ليال اختيار استهلها بابرز
العناوين
[موسيقى]
الرئيس التركي يرفع عدد الولايات المنكوبه
الى احدى عشره ولايه وفرق الانقاذ توقف
البحث عن ناجين جدد بهطاي حتى صباح غد
مزيد من المساعدات الامميه الى سوريا
وانفراج على المعابر الداخليه بين الاكراد
والنظام
[موسيقى]
مع اقتراب الذكرى الاولى لبدء الحرب في
اوكرانيا الناتو يحذر بيلاروسيا من تبعات
التورط الى جانب موسكو
لتضييق الخناقه على الحرس الثوري رئيسه
المفوضيه الاوروبيه تقترح فرض المزيد من
العقوبات على ايران
[موسيقى]
اليوم العاشر من الزلزال وهول الكارثه
التي خلفها وراءه على جانبي حدوده في
سوريا وتركيا اعداد الضحايا بلغ اكثر من
اربعين الف قتيل فيما رفع الرئيس التركي
عدد الولايات المنكوبه الى احدى عشره
ولايه بعد تصنيف الازيب اما عن فرق فرق
الانقاذ وبالرغم من تضاؤل الامال الا انها
ما تزال تعثر على المزيد من الناجين بعد
اكثر من 230 ساعه على الكارثه منهم من قضى
اكثر من 200 ساعه تحت الانقاذ وخرج ناجيا
وعلى ذكر فرق الانقاذ فقد لجا بعضها الى
استخدام الفضاء للبحث عن مزيد من العالقين
كتقنيه فايندر التي تستخدم الان بتركيا
للبحث عن الاشخاص المحاصرين تحت الانقاض
[موسيقى]
هون هون
يا رب
لا
يلا قولي يا رب وصلت قريب عليك خمس دقايق
قولي يا رب
[موسيقى]
يا شباب اعطونا حرام نغطيه
مزيد من التفاصيل مشاهدينا منها
عمار الهندي عمار مع توقف اعمال البحث عن
ناجين بهذه المنطقه كنا قد تبعنا معك يعني
رص احوال
اهالي الضحايا الموجودين هناك كيف هي صوره
من هناك
البرد قارص جدا ليال وانا وددت ان يعني ان
نتجول معكم في هذا المخيم الذي هو يعني في
حديقه بين شارعين هذه طبعا اسر تركيا
وسوريا ويعني من الجميع من كل من تضرروا
وسقطت بناياتهم يسكنون هذه الخيام يشعرون
النيران منهم اطفال ومنهم نساء وانا ساجور
في الكاميرا طبعا
المشكله الحقيقيه ان البرد قارص جدا وهذه
العائلات
لم تبلغ حتى هذه اللحظه ما الخطوه التاليه
في حياتهم بعد هذه الخيام يعني هل ستكون
الحياه باكملها بالنسبه لهم
في خيام ام سيتغير الحال وستكون هنالك خطه
بديله لهم في اقادم الايام اعدادهم كبيره
اغلبهم من السوريين من العائلات السوريه
التي فقدت منازلها
باتت للاسف الشديد في الشارع طبعا
غذاء متوفر ماء متوفر ولكن البرد الشديد
هو اكبر تحدي لهم وخصوصا للاطفال كنت
تحدثت الى بعض العائلات طبعا تاتي منظمات
دوليه واطباء يعني
يقوموا بفحص الاطفال هنالك طبعا
الانفلونزا بين الاطفال من الجراء البرد
الشديد منتشره بينهم وهنالك طبعا سعال
شديد بين الاطفال وهنالك مرضى سكري من
النساء والرجال في هذا المخيم كنت شاهدتهم
اليوم طبعا الاضاءه غير متوفره بشكل كامل
هنالك مولدات ان كنت تسمعي صوتها هم
يعتمدون في التدفئه وهنا
نعم وهنا عائله انا ودت يعني سريعا ان كان
لدينا وقت فقط اتحدث اليهم يعني يشرحوا
لنا ظروف الحياه هذه السيده المسنه مثلا
مصابه بالسكري ليال وهذا المرض المزمن
بسبب عدم تلقي العلاج المناسب يعني احدث
لديها مشكله في الحركه في رجليها وصارت
حركتها اصعب ووضع اصعب السلام عليكم
يعطيكم الف عافيه بدي اسلم اولا على الحجه
واتطمن على صحتها انا كنت شفتك اليوم وكنت
تعبانه شوي كيف صرتي الحمد لله رب
العالمين الحمد لله احسن الحمد لله
ما حدا لسه اجاكي عشان ادويه ولا عشان شيء
صح لان ما حدا عندي طيب هلا انت شو
هذا الجرح من ايش من السكر ولا من الزلزال
اه ايش صار له اصبعك من الزلزال
سلامتك الف سلامه طيب انا بس بدي اسالك
انت هلا المشكله في البرد الشديد بالنسبه
لك مؤذي للسكر انت شو تحتاجي علاج ايش
الاشياء اللي ناقصه عليه
عندك متوفر ادويه
مبارح رح جاب لي زرف للضغط والظرف للسكر
سلامتك الف سلامه طيب انتو كنتو ساكنين في
بيت وبشكل جيد والان للاسف الشديد يعني
بدي احكي باريحيه الامر انتهى في الشارع
ايش خططكم وين راح تروحوا وبعدين ايش ايش
راح تعملوا في الحياه
حدا حكى معكم حدا بلغكم ايش راح يصير
ولا منظمات ولا اي حدا ولا حدا اجى
عمار هل العوده الى سوريا وارده لدي
ساسهل ساساله لا هو يقول انه هنالك منظمه
اتت واخبرتهم عن شيء
انا عندي ابن بالمشفى واولاده ميتين وما
بعرف وين كم طفل فقدتم
الله يبارك فيك وابوهم وضعه صعب واليوم
كان عنده عمليه وامبارح كانوا عاملين له
عمليه والحمد لله رب العالمين يعني انت
بجوز اهم شيء تريد الان هو المسكن طبعا
هاي عشره ايام ما حدا نزل المي على راسه
يعني ما في ما في حمام ما في
اذا تامن الامن والامان
طريق معبر باب الهوى وعلى الشمال السوري
ما النا حدا بالمحرر المنطقه المحرره ما
لنا حدا يا جماعه من اللاذقيه وتهجرنا
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا مشاهدينا من شمال ادلب الصحافي
مسلم السيد عيسى ومن معبر باب الهوى
الصحافه محمد الاشقر سابدا معك محمد من
معبر باب الهوى قبل السؤال عن المساعده
بما اننا تحدثنا عنها طيله هذا النهار
هناك عدد كبير من السوريين الذين عبروا
هذا المعبر عائدين الى شمالي غربي سوريا
ان كان من عاد الى المنطقه بسبب عدم وجود
ماوى بتركيا وان كان جسامين هل رصدتم
الاعداد التي دخلت الى هناك
نعم يعني الى حد هذه اللحظه يستمر توافد
السوريين
الناجين من الزلزال الذي ضرب تركيا حاملي
البطاقه بطاقه الحمايه المؤقته الصادره عن
الولايات المتضرره في تركيا الى حد هذه
اللحظه طبعا وصل عدد الاشخاص الذين دخلوا
الاراضي السوريه الى حد هذه اللحظه اكثر
من 1250 شخص هذا الرقم قبل قبل دخول ثلاثه
حافلات قبل قليل اي ان العدد تخطى
1250 شخص حتى هذه اللحظه ويستمر توافد
السوريين بحسب
العاملين هنا قالوا انهم سيواصلون العمل
حتى دخول جميع الموجودين في المعبر من
الجانب التركي طبعا يعني
يتم تامين هؤلاء الوافدين باتجاه
بالقرب باتجاه القرب من مدينه سرمدا في
ريف ادلب ومن ثم الذهاب بهم الى اقاربهم
في عموم ريف ادلب
تامين من لا ماوى لهم هنا في المنطقه طبعا
اما بالنسبه
لجثامين القتلى الذين سقطوا في تركيا فدخل
الى حد هذه اللحظه منذ بدايه الكارثه اكثر
من 1400 جنازه تم دخولها عن طريق معبر باب
الهوى اسمح لي ان انتقل الى مسلم مسلم
يعني اليوم شاهدنا خرق على المستوى
الانساني والسياسي مع دخول مساعدات كرديه
الى المناطق التي سيطر عليها النظام حامله
الاعلام الكرديه لاداره قصد مع ما يعنيه
من خرق جديد وايضا قبل الى مناطق المعارضه
هل لديك تفاصيل عن المساعدات التي دخلت
والتي ستدخل في الايام المقبله لو سمحت
نعم يعني في الحقيقه يبدو ان الحاله
العامه يعني الاسبوع الاول او العشره ايام
الاولى من هذه الكارثه وعمليه المناشدات
والنداءات الاستغاثه يبدو انها بدات
بالتحسن بشكل تدريجي على ارض الواقع سواء
عبر دخول المساعدات عبر الحدود الى
المناطق المعارضه اولا ثم انتقالها الى
مناطق
قصد ومناطق النظام وبالعكس هذه العمليه
بصراحه هي معقده جدا حتى اللحظه هناك يعني
تشبه الكثير من التفاصيل والتعقيدات على
ارض الواقع نتيجه انتقال هذه الشاحنات بين
مناطق مختلفه وصولا الى وجهتها الاخيره
سواء كانت الى مناطق النظام المتضرره او
المناطق الخاضعه لسيطره المعارضه لكن
بالتالي حتى اللحظه هو تحسن وصول
المساعدات وخصوصا انا هنا اتحدث عن
المساعدات التابعه للامم المتحده بشقيها
تصل مساعدات لصندوق الغذاء العالمي
كاحد مؤسسات الامم المتحده وايضا لمنظمه
اليونيسف بتفاصيلها المساعدات التي وصلت
حتى اللحظه هي مساعدات غذائيه ومساعدات
شتويه وايضا مساعدات مخصصه للاطفال
والنساء وايضا المساعدات الخاصه بالخيام
ومراكز الايواء اسمح لي مسلم ان يعني ارصد
الصوره من على معبر باب الهوى ما الذي
ارصدتموه هناك من مساعدات وصلت محمد عبر
هذا المعبر بالذات خصوصا انه المعبر
الاساسي الذي تنقل عبر الامم المتحده كل
المساعدات اتحدث عن مساعدات امميه وان كان
مساعدات من دول اخرى
نعم يعني في الحقيقه عدد الشاحنات التي
دخلت الى حد هذه اللحظه منذ يوم الخميس
الى اليوم هو 106 شاحنات تحمل مساعدات
امميه اخرها كان اليوم عندما دخلت 22
شاحنه عبر معبر باب الهواء الحدودي مع
تركيا الشاحنات محمله بمختلف انواع
المساعدات الاغاثيه الغذائيه والغير
غذائيه وهنا اقصد بعض
المواد
ومستلزمات الخيام وغيرها من المواد
اللازمه للمتضررين
المنتشرين في عموم مناطق شمال غرب سوريا
طبعا هناك معبر اخر ثاني في ريف حلب دخلت
منه ايضا
عده شاحنات محمله بالمساعدات الامميه وهو
معبر باب السلامه الحدودي مع تركيا في ريف
حلب الشمالي حيث الى حد هذه اللحظه ثلاثه
عشر شاحنه محمله بالمساعدات الاماميه يوم
امس دخل 11 شاحنه واليوم رصد دخول
شاحنتين من معبر باب السلامه الحدود مع
تركيا في ريف حلب الشمال عن المعابر اسمح
لي محمدا اسال مسلم عن هذا الموضوع مسلم
يعني كان هناك مطالبات منذ بدايه هذا
الزلزال بفتح معابر اضافيه ما هي المعابر
التي فتحت حتى الساعه ما اليه فتحه
المسموح ما الغير مسموع ولا اي متى ستبقى
مفتوحه
نعم هناك توضيح جدا مهم في هذا السياق ان
المعابر مع تركيا هي خمس معابر كانت
مفتوحه بالسابق لكن كان هناك معبر واحد
مخصص لدخول
الامميه وهو معبر باب الهوى اما المعابر
الاخرى فقد تم افتتاحها في هذه الازمه
لدخول الشاحنات التي تاتي عبر دول العالم
المختلفه سواء كانت حكومات العربيه او
المساعدات التركيه لكن التوضيح المهم ان
المساعدات الامميه التي تدخل بموافقه مجلس
الامن الاخيره قبل التي تم تمديدها قبل
ثلاث اشهر تدخل حصرا عبر معبر باب الهوى
ثم يتم توزيعها وهذا حقيقه يعني هناك نقطه
في هذا السياق مهمه ان المساعدات الامميه
تاخذ وقتا طويلا حتى تصل الى المناطق
المنكوبه وخصوصا ان كانت ستعبر الى ارياف
حلب الشماليه والشرقيه وغيرها لان
المساعدات تعبر من معبر واحد فقط وهنا
اتحدث عن المساعدات التابعه للامم المتحده
اما المعابر الاخرى وهي
معبر باب السلامه مع محافظه حلب معبر
الحمام في عفرين وايضا معبر الراعي ومعبر
جرابلس هذه المعابر كلها مفتوحه تماما قبل
وقوع الكارثه مع الحدود السوريه التركيه
لعبور المساعدات التي تاتي من الدول
المختلفه والتي تاتي من المنظمات لكن
بالمقابل كما ذكرت ان المساعدات الامميه
التي تدخل من معبر باب الهوى بالتحديد
تاخذ وقتا طويلا
لتصل الى المستحقين والمستفيدين في عموم
المناطق المتضرره شكرا لكما
مسلم سيد عيسى حدثتنا من ادلب وايضا من
معبر باب الهوى الصحافه محمد الاشقر شكرا
لكم على هذه الرسائل
[موسيقى]
وبالحديث مشاهدينا عن المعابر والمساعدات
فبعد عشره ايام على اسوا زلزال تشهده
المنطقه منذ قرن ورغم الكارثه الانسانيه
التي هزت العالم ما زالت المساعي الامميه
لايصال المساعدات الى شمال غربي سوريا
تواجه تحديات كثيره هنا على الحدود
السوريه التركيه يوجد اكثر من عشره معابر
ولكن ثلاثه منها لها اهميه كبرى بايصال
المساعدات الانسانيه لسكان شمال سوريا وهي
باب الهوى باب السلامه و باب الراعي كما
نشاهد بهذه الخارطه معبر باب الهوى هو في
الوقت الراهن المعبر الرسمي الوحيد في
شمال ادلب بقرار اممي اي بموجه بقرار مجلس
الامن الدولي وتسيطر على معبر باب الهوى
المعارضه السوريه
العسكريه معبر باب السلامه في منطقه اعزاز
شمال حلب سيساهم ايضا بشكل كبير بادخال
المساعدات الانسانيه الى هذه المنطقه
المنكوبه طبعا المعبر وافقت على فتح الامم
المتحده مؤخرا تسيطر عليها ايضا فصائل
المعارضه السوريه اما معبر الراعي في ريف
حلب يعتبر ايضا شريان رئيسي للمتضررين في
المنطقه حيث طالبت واشنطن ودول غربيه
بفتحه لايصال المساعدات واستجابت الامم
المتحده لتلك المطالب ووافقت على استخدامه
بعد موافقه نظام الاسد طبعا علما انه اي
معبر اي معبر الراعي هو تحت سيطره
المعارضه السوريه
[موسيقى]
يضم الينا مشاهدينا عبر سكايت من اسطنبول
الدكتور مهدي داوود رئيس جمعيه النور
السوريه دكتور مهدي سابدا بالسؤال الاساسي
اليوم بما ان السوريين يعني هناك عدد منهم
بظل هذا الزلزال ذهب وعاد الى الشمال
السوري هناك مهله ثلاثه اشهر اعطيت لهؤلاء
على ان يتم ابلاغهم بالخطوه اللاحقه بعد
انشاء مراكز ايواء ما المتوقع من قبل
السلطات التركيه بهذا الموضوع بالذات
يسعد مساكم وشكرا على استضافه طبعا بصراحه
الحكومه التركيه الان هي عاجزه عن ايواء
الاتراك نفسهم لذلك حتى في مخيمات او بعض
الدور السكن اللي كان موجود فيها السوريين
تم اخلائها
وتم اخلاء هذه المخيمات وتم
ارسالهم الى بعض منهم الى سوريا وقسم منهم
تم ارسالهم الى مناطق اخرى او مده اخرى
نعم فلذلك الان الدوره التركيه بصراحه غير
قادره على استيعاب الاتراك نفسه
دكتور مهدي يعني نحن نتحدث بالولايات
المنكوبه وحده نتحدث عن مئات الاف
السوريين كان هناك احصائيه بالامس يعني
فصلت اعداد بالمناطق والولايات المنكوبه
ما الذي سيحل بهؤلاء خصوصا وان يعني خطط
الاسكان واعاده الاعمار للاتراك غير واضحه
حتى الساعه حتى المخيمات ومخيمات الوشوء
بصراحه وضع السورين حاليا بتركيا وخاصه
الناس الموجودين في المناطق المنكوبيه
طبعا سوريا حاليا الموجودين داخل تركيا
يغاثون من قبل وكالات او جمعيات سوريه
اهليه وايضا من قبل مؤسسات ايضا دائما
للشان السوري سواء كانت عربيه او غير
عربيه طبعا الان الى الان الدعم على
استحياء
وهناك مشاكل بالوصول الحوالات النقديه الى
داخل التركي او
الحوات
حسابات الجمعيات السوريه خاصه لذلك يعني
حاليا وضع
السوريين في تركيا نحن كمؤسسات نحاول ان
ننسق مع الجهات الحكوميه التركيه لانه
جهود الحكومه التركيه او استطاعت حكومه
تركيا اكبر بكثير من المؤسسات لذلك
اليوم كان في عنا اجتماع مع بلديه اسطنبول
وتم الحاق
الناس الموجودين باسطنبول ايضا بالمتدرين
من الزلزال كان يتم الفصل اولا عن بين
الاتراك والسوريين اما الان في اسطنبول ان
شاء الله بلديه اسطنبول القرار بان لا فرق
بين السوري والتركي في التعامل
استاذ مهدي يعني هذه المنطقه من تركيا
كانت تعتبر موطن اللجوء الاول للسوريين
الذين تهجروا من المناطق السوريه وتحديدا
الذين دخلوا عبر الشمال السوري اليوم يعني
اصبحت ايضا هي هي غير قادره على استيعاب
اهلها ما الخطوات التاليه التي ممكن ان
تقومون بها خصوصا ان هناك حالات كثيره
بحاجه لاعاده اعمار بحاجه لتبابا بحاجه
لكل شيء هل قادره المؤسسات الرسميه على
المساعده
هلا بصراحه بالداخل التركي بموضوع الاعمار
هو خاص بالدوله التركيه ومل الدوله
التركيه تسمح لحدا بالتدخل بموضوع الاعمار
ولكن بخصوص عوده الناس للداخل السوري لان
الناس العايده للداخل ايضا بحاجه الى
اغاثه بحاجه الى ايضا للسكن بحاجه الى قيم
بحاجه الى ابسط مقومات الشتاء خاصه الجو
الشتاء والجو
بارد جدا في الداخل السوري ايضا في في
جنوب تركيا فلذلك يعني
موضوع المساعدات الانسانيه البحث من
مساعدات غذائيه او صحيه نحن ان شاء الله
سنكون قادرين على تلبيه حاجات اخواتنا
السوريين الذين هم بحاجه اما من ناحيه
اعاده الاعمال هي على كاهل الدوله التركيه
والدوله التركيه هي بدون اعطت اعلان وبدات
اليوم باعطاء
اجور النفقات الاجور لبعض العوائل
وارسالها الى حساباتهم شكرا لك دكتور مهدي
داوود رئيس جمعيه نور السوريه حدثتنا من
اسطنبول
كشفت تركيا عن خططها لاعاده مدمره زلزال
في المناطق المنكوبه واكدت وزاره البيئه
والتخطيط العمراني والتغير المناخي ان
اعاده الاعمار ستبدا نهايه الشهر الجاري
كما اوضحت الوزاره انه تم تحديد حوالي
اثنين واربعين الف مبنى في عشره مقاطعات
تضررت في كهرمان ومرعش واشارت الى ان
الحكومه تخطط لاستكمال تقييم الاضرار في
المحافظات المتضرره من الزلزال خلال اسبوع
وسيتم بناء حوالي 300 الف مبنى سكني في
المناطق المتضرره في تركيا جراء الزلزال
وفق طبعا وسائل اعلام تركيا هذا وكشف
الخبراء ان 98% من المباني المدمره تم
بناؤها قبل العام 1999 بعدما تعرضت تركيا
لزلزال مدمر اعتمدت اثره قوانين بناء
جديده
[موسيقى]
يا عمري
خلف زلزال تركيا وسوريا الكثير من القصص
الماساويه لاشخاص فقدوا اقربهم وذويهم من
بينهم سيده مسنه في ريف ادلب توفي خمسه من
احفادها كما تعرض ابنائها لاصابات بليغه
جيبولي الميه ويجوا لعندي
ولا وعد
راحوا كل يوم راح اولاده
كلمات قليله قد لا تختزل حجم معاناه هذه
السيده التي وجدت نفسها بين ليله وضحاها
وحيده بعدما خسرت من كانوا يسندون ظهرها
ويعينونها على عاديات الزمان
لحظه لم تتجاوز الدقيقه كانت كافيه لتجعل
هذه السيده تعيش ماساه حقيقيه اصابه
ابنيها ووفاه احفادها حتى منزلها لم يتبقى
منه سوى الانقاض التي جلست تبكي عليها
حسره وحزنا على قساوه المقاله اولادي
وانا مستاجر اللي تحت غادي انا والخيار
مستاجرين اللي ما عندي بنت عشقه قاعدين ما
شفت
مقاعدوني قالوا لي البنيه يا ولادك جيت
[ضحك]
تزال ذهب بخمسه من احفادها وادى الى
اصابات بليغه بابنها والاثنين
واحد مكسور ظهره واعد مقصوره رقبته
[موسيقى]
ولسه تقول اللي يقول يروح يبدا يتفرج دار
اولادي
السيده ترفض مغادره المكان فاين لها ان
تذهب ومن عاشت لاجلهم لسنوات التهمهم
الزلزال والدمار
م قبل ما يشيلوه كل امنيتها الان ايجاد
جفاميل المفقودين تحت الانقاض والقاء نظره
وداع اخيرا لن تواسيها حجم الماساه وسام
الذهبي العربيه
ينضم مشاهدينا الينا من مدينه سرمدا شمال
ادلب منير المصطفى نائب مدير الدفاع
المدني السوري استاذ منير سابدا من هذه
المعاناه التي سمعناها الان ومن هذه يعني
الماساه هناك الكثيرين يرفضون مغادره
الدمار الموجود ومغادره منازلهم المدمره
لانهم يريدون رؤيه جثمين اقاربهم ومن لهم
وذويهم اليوم طبعا عمليه العمليه الاولى
وهي عمليه البحث عن ناجين انتهت تقريبا
ولكن عمليات انتشال الجثث والضحايا اين
اصبحت
في الحقيقه يعني حالات ماساويه كثيره
لحالات كثيره
نشاهدها كل يوم ونتابعها مع المدنيين
الذين بقوا على قيد الحياه وفقدوا يعني
الكثير من افراد عوائلهم نسال الله الرحمه
لكل من قضى في هذا الزلزال ونسال الله
الشفاء العاجل لكل من اصيب في هذا الزلزال
بالنسبه للخواز البيضاء في الحقيقه نحن
انتقلنا الى مرحله انتشال الضحايا
والجثانيم من تحت انقاذ المنازل طبعا
قطعنا خطوات كثيره ووصلنا الى مرحله
استطعنا انتشال تقريبا اكثر الضحايا تحت
هذه الانقاض وبقي القديم هل هناك عدد
تقريبي عن الضحايا يعني التي ما زالت
موجوده تحت الانقاض اتحدث عن المفقودين
في الحقيقه نحن حاليا الفرق متواجده في
اماكن العمل وهي تبحث عن المفقودين وتعتمد
بشكل كبير على المعلومات الوارده من
الاهالي من ذوي الضحايا انا لا اتكلم عن
اعداد كبيره نسال الله ان تكون هذه
الاعداد صغيره ونسال الله ان يكونوا هؤلاء
المفقودين ليسوا متواجدين تحت الانقراض بل
هم قد يكون في احد المشافي او النقاط
الطبيه وهم في حاله قد تكون صحيه غير
قادرين التواصل مع ذويهم فنحن لا نتمنى ان
نجد ولكن الاعداد التقريبيه
لا يوجد اعداد محفوظه بشكل بشكل كامل ولكن
نحن نتكلم يعني عن اعداد لا تتجاوز 15
للعشرين شخص مفقود تحت هذه الانقاذ يعني
مفقودين وقد لا يكون هم ضحايا ونسال الله
ان يكون
احادرين على القيام بهذه المهمه حتى مع
الامكانات المحدوده الموجوده لديكم
في الحقيقه نحن فرقنا موجوده لا زاد حتى
الان في اماكن الزيارات وهي تنطلق فورا
باتجاه الاماكن التي يتوقع فيها وجود بعض
الضحايا طبعا نتيجه المعلومات الوارده من
هؤلاء المدينه ونقوم بالبحث مره اخرى في
هذا المكان
ومحاوله يعني
محاوله قلب هذه الانقاذ او بعد هذه
الانقاض حتى نبحث عن هؤلاء المفقودين طبعا
ترافق هذه العمليه ايضا عمليه اخرى وهي
جدا مهمه اصبحت هي فتح الطرقات المؤديه
الى المتضرين من هذا الزلزال من اجل
الوصول المساعدات التي باتت تدخل بفضل
الله من اكثر من معبر باتجاه شمال غرب
سوريا وبدات تصل الى هؤلاء المتضرين صحيح
انها يعني انا اقول لا زالت خجوله حتى
الان وهي غير كافيه للاحتياجات السكان
المتدرين من هذا الزلزال ولكن نسال الله
ان تكون الايام القادمه هناك دخول اكبر
واسرع من خصوصا ان هؤلاء يعني حتى ما قبل
الزلزال كانوا بحاله حاجه وعواز واليوم
طبعا زادت اكثر بكثير شكرا لك استاذ منير
المصطفى نائب مدير الدفاع المدني السوري
حدثتنا من شمال ادلب
مشاهدينا التاسعه مستمره ولكن بعد قليل
وتتابعون فيها بسبب الزلزال تحذيرات من
خطر انتشار امراض واوبئه ما بعد الكوارث
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد لم يكن باستطاعه الطبيب
عبد الباسط خليل ومساعده زوجته وطفلته بعد
ما علقتا تحت الانقاض في لحظات الزلزال
الاولى فقد كان يحمل على عاتقه اسعاف
وانقاذ من يمكن من المصابين والجرحى في
ريف ادلب المزيد في هذا التقرير الخاص
ومع تجاوز عدد الضحايا في سوريا
3500 قتيل تنعكس صوره ما الت اليه الاوضاع
في المنطقه المنكوبه شمالي سوريا على
ملامح وجه الطبيب وصوته
الناس تعتبر ان الطبيب هو البطل في كل
مواقف وبينسوا انه هو انسان مثل مثله
وعنده عيله وعنده واطفال لم ينفي عبد
الباسط تعبه ومواجهه لكنه لم ينفي ايضا ان
الاطباء هنا قاوموا مشاعرهم رغم حجم
خسائرهم واصبحوا اليوم بحاجه لمن يداويهم
فرق الانقاذ بتركيا اصبحت ترده ملابس
العزل خشيت من انتشار الامراض والاوبئه
لاسيما مع تحذيرات امميه من خطر انتشار
اوبئه ما بعد الزلزال والكوارث
اليوم العاشر على الزلزال المدمر الذي ضرب
تركيا بدات تختفي عمليات البحث عن الناجين
تحت الانقاض العمليات هنا تتركز على
انتشال الجثث الموتى والمفقودين وفرق
الانقاذ بدات تاخذ شكلا ولونا جديدا ترتدي
ملابس العزل خشيه الامراض والاوبئه
وانتشارها خصوصا مع وجود اعداد كبيره من
الجثامين التي لا تزال تحت انقاض البنايات
المدمره في انطاكيا في هاتاي واسر تبحث
عمن لديها من المفقودين والذين لم يعرف
مصيرهم حتى اللحظه
عمار الهندي انطاكيا
ينضم الينا مشاهدينا عبر سكايب من لندن
الدكتور عبد الكريم قزيز باحث في كينج من
لندن وامين سر الجمعيه الطبيه السوريه
البريطانيه دكتور يعني من المعلوم الطبيا
بان الجثه تبدا بالتحلل لحظه الوفاه ولكن
الظروف المحيطه بها ظروف اتحدثون عن درجات
الحراره ظروف الطبيعيه التربه وكل ما الى
هناك تؤثر على سرعه التحلل بالموجود اليوم
بزلزال تركيا عن كم يوم نتحدث
نعم اسعد الله مسائكم يعني للاسف بعد هذه
الكارثه فعلا نخشه من موضوع الامراض
الساريه والموضوع السؤال حول الجثث التي
هي تحت الانقاض هذا الامر قد ياخذ وقت
اطول من العاده بسبب درجات الحراره
المنخفضه التي تشهدها المنطقه يعني في بعض
المناطق درجات الحراره تنخفض ما تحت الصفر
مما قد يؤخر تحلل الجثث ولكن بنفس الوقت
هذا التحلل هي عمليه تبدا بشكل تدريجي
والمشكله هنا انه اذا كان هناك مرض ساري
لاي من الاشخاص ضمن تحت الانقاض وبالتالي
هذه الامراض الساريه قد تتطور اثناء تحلل
الجثه نتحدث هنا عن العديد من الامراض مثل
الامراض السل التهاب الكبد الاي والبي
امراض مثل نقص المناعه المكتسب والتهابات
السحايا وغيرها كل هذه الامراض قد تنتشر
من الجثث التي بدات بالتحلل وهذه العمليه
قد تاخذ اسبوع او عشره ايام عشره ايام
حتى يتم معاملته الجثه بشكل جيد من حيث
اما الدفن او وضعها في اكياس مناسبه هناك
يعني هناك نظامين تضررا ايضا بسبب هذا
الزلزال نظام الصرف الصحي نظام ايضا
المياه عندما نتحدث عن تضرر هذين النظامين
نتحدث عن خطر امراض جديده الكوليرا وغيره
من الامراض كيف تنتشر مع تضرر هذين
النظامين
نعم يعني بعد اي جائحه طبيعيه مثل كارثه
طبيعيه مثل الزلزال او الفيضانات نخشه من
النوعين من الامراض امراض تنتقل عبر الماء
بسبب تدمر البنيه التحتيه الخاصه بالمياه
وامراض تنتشر عبر الهواء بسبب الاكتظاظ
السكاني وبسبب ظروف الملاجئ السيئه التي
عاده يقيم فيها النازحين وبالتالي في هذه
الكارثه الان نتحدث بشكل اساسي الان عن
امراض منتقله عبر الماء وخاصه الكوليرا
يعني لا ننسى ان سوريا شمال غرب سوريا
كانوا يعاني من الكوليرا الصيف الماضي الى
الان كانت هناك اكثر من 85 الف حاله في
سوريا وايضا كان حتى منتشره الى لبنان
وبالتالي وجود الان هذه الكارثه وتضرر بنى
الصف الصحي ومياه الشرب قد يؤثر بشكل كبير
على انتشار الكوليرا بشكل اكبر بكثير
ولذلك لابد بالتحديد على الكوليرا لابد من
توفير شي مياه شرب نظيفه الترصد الوبائي
لكشف الحالات وعلاجها وايضا توسيع الفمويه
التي قد يعني تكون يعني
اسال عنه التحسبا يعني لا لكي لا ننتقل
الى مشكله
اكبر والبروتوكولات الممكن اتخاذها للحد
من انتشار الامراض وكيفيه التعامل مع
الجثث
نعم يعني
ثلاثه امور امور خاصه بالماء امور خاصه
بالملاجئ ومناطق النزوح وامور خاصه
بالامراض المتقله عبر الطفيليات مثل
البعوض مثلا الامور الخاصه بالمياه تامين
مياه شرب نظيفه تامين ترصد وبائي لكشف
الحالات وعلاجها وتوزيع اللقاحات اللقاحات
الكولر الفمويه هي مهمه جدا الان وايضا
السوائل الفمويه نحن نعلم ان الكولر هو
مرض قد يميت في غضون ساعات بسبب نقص
الاماهه بسبب تجفاف وبالتالي السوائل
الفمويه ومهمه جدا الشوارع الفمويه امر
اخر هما ما يخص الملاجئ يعني الان بسبب
وجود عدد كبير من الناس في مكان يعني
تعتبر امكنه صغيره هذه الامكنه احيانا لا
تتوفر فيها شروط الدنيا لعلاجه وهذا الحال
بشكل خاص في سوريا الامر قد يؤدي الى
انتشار الانفلونزا والكوفيد بشكل كبير
وايضا مرض مثلا الان المنطقه فيها مرضيه
بشكل كبير قد يعود والذي ينتقل عبر البعوض
لذلك لابد من تاني نحن نتحدث عن خطر تحول
المنطقه من منطقه
منكوب في كينج لندن وامين سيرج جمعيه
الجمعيه الطبيه السوريه البريطانيه
شدد وزير الدفاع العراقي ثابت العباسي في
تصريحات الخاصه للعربيه على رفض
انتهاكات واشكال التعدي من قبل ميليشيات
ايران قبل ان اخذ هذه هذا الخبر مشاهدينا
التاسعه مستمره ونتابع في السياقه ولكن
بعد قليل
باستخدام المناطيط كذريعه لفرض مزيد من
العقوبات على الصين
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد مشاهدينا شدد وزير
الدفاع العراقي ثابت العباسي في تصريحات
خاصه للعربيه على رفض كل اشكال التعدي على
سياده العراق مشيرا الى ان الحكومه
العراقيه ستعمل على توفير الامكانيات
والسلاح اللازم للحفاظ على سياده العراق
السياده خط احمر ولا يمكن السماح ولا
التهاون في هذا الموضوع الرجال موجودين
معاليه في الحفاظ على السياده لكن يحتاجون
لادوات والى امور تساندهم في هذا الموضوع
هذا المجال
تكاد تكون هذه الحكومه الحكومه
لا اقول الوحيده بل
من الحكومات التي ذاقت كافه القوى
السياسيه المنضويه في تشكيلات الحكومه
وعود كامله لدوله رئيس الوزراء والوزاره
الدفاع بتوفير الفرص الكامله
للتسليح لغرض الحفاظ على السياده ولغرض
تعزيز القدرات العسكريه لوزاره الدفاع
في سوريا كشفت مصادر مطلعه للعربيه مواصله
مسؤولين في النظام السوري انتاج الاسلحه
الكيميائيه وعدم عزمهم التخلي عن صناعتها
المصادر اوضحت ان فرع 450 في مركز البحوث
العلميه السوريه لا يزال يعمل بشكل صريحه
اليوم ومسؤول عن تخزين الاسلحه الكيماويه
الاستراتيجيه في سوريا واكد مصادر العربيه
ان الوحده بقياده غسان عباس تقوم بتوظيف
علماء من مركز البحوث العلميه لاعاده
تاسيس صناعه غاز السارين في سوريا ويعمل
على انشاء البنيه التحتيه اللازمه عدد
قليل من المهندسين من بينهم سمير صلاح
فيما شارك الدكتور نزار حسن بايجاد طريقه
جديده لانتاج غاز السرين اعتمادا على
المواد الخام التي لا تخضع للرقابه
الى الحرب الاوكرانيه مشاهدينا ونبدا من
الميدان حيث اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
عن تراجع القوات الاوكرانيه لمسافه ثلاثه
كيلومترات في لوغاسك ونشرت وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه في ديون لتحصينات اوكرانيه على
اراضي لوغاسك اخترقها العسكريون الروس في
المنطقه العسكريه المركزيه واكد الدفاع
الروسيه ان القوات الاوكرانيه غادرت
مواقعها على عجل
وتركوا معدات عسكريه والقتله
حذر وزير دفاع الشمال الاطلسي خلال
الاجتماعهم في بروكسيل حذروا بيلاروسيا من
عواقب التورط بحرب اوكرانيا كما اعلنوا عن
رفع الانفاق العسكري بقيمه الناتج المحلي
لكل دوله وبحث الوزراء ما اذا كان الهدف
الحليب بانفاق اثنين بالمئه من الناتج
المحلي هو امر كافر خصوصا مع اندلاع الحرب
في اوكرانيا
هذا ووصلت كاميرا العربيه الى الخط
الحدودي الفاصل بين بيلاروسيا واوكرانيا
عند معبر ديفين سما ريال مغلق خلال هذه
الفتره على خلفيه الازمه بين موسكو والغرب
الزميل عبد الجواد الرشد من هناك يضعنا
بصوره الاوضاع وكيف يبدو شكل الحدود على
خلفيه الصراع الاوكراني فلنتابع
هذا هو معبر ديفين على الشريط الحدودي
الفاصل بين بيلاروسيا واوكرانيا وقد غدا
بهذا الشكل اغلاق كامل لحركه العبور بين
الجانبين وترقب كبير يزيد الطين بالله مع
مرور عام تقريبا على بدء العمليه العسكريه
الروسيه في الاراضي الاوكرانيه
جميع نقاط المرور من والى بيلاروسيا لا
تعمل خلال الوقت الحالي سواء القطارات
السيارات او
الحافلاتها تحتاط من الخطر بقوات من جيشها
تدعم حرس الحدود وترا في خطوات كيف
الاستفزازيه كما وصفتها خطوه نحو مزيد من
التصعيد بين الجانبين
الوضع اليوم مع الجانب الاوكراني صعب
للغايه خاصه في ظل استفزازات كيف وتسييرها
لدرونات غير حربيه فوق مناطقنا الحدوديه
هذا المركز هو واحد من بين 32 معبرا بين
الدولتين جميعها مغلقه حتى اليوم المتضر
اكبر حسبه روايه السلطات هم سكان المناطق
المجاوره الذين كانوا يتمتعون بخاصيه
التنقل بحريه بين القرى الحدوديه دون
تاشيره عبور للعمل وتبادل البضائع
التجاريه بين الجانبين عبد الجواد الروش
لقناتي العربيه والحدث من الحدود
البيلاروسيه الاوكرانيه
وايضا يكمل معنا عبد جواد الرشد من الحدود
البيلاروسيا الاوكرانيه عبد الجواد يعني
كيف هي الصوره من هناك كنت نقلت بهذا
التقرير عمليه المراقبه البيلاروسيه
للحدود ماذا من تفاصيل اكثر حول هذه حول
الحدود هناك
مساء الخير ليال لا يمكن الحديث عن ان
الحدود البيلاروسيه الاوكرانيه هي هادئه
بشكل ما الوضع اشبه انصحها التعبير
بالقنبله الموقوطه طبعا استعدادات الى
الجنبين جاهل الجانبين شاهدناها طبعا على
الجانب البيلاروسي وتحدث القائمون على حرس
الحدود اللي هناك بانهم يلاحظون ايضا
تجهيزات من قبل الجانب الاوكراني طبعا حرس
الحدود البيلاروسي هو المسؤول او الاول
والاخير عن الشريط الفاصل بين الدولتين
لكنه يحظى اليوم بدعم من سلطات وقوات
الجيش
البيلاروسيه في تلك المنطقه هناك معدات من
العيار الثقيل هي اسلحه ثقيله هي تجهيزات
حديثه طبعا ما كنا نشاهده في الدومباس وفي
مناطق اخرى في جنوب الاوكراني نلاحظه
اليوم في شمال اوكرانيا على الخط الحدودي
الفاصل هي تجهيزات واستعداد هو قلق كبير
قد يتحول الى صراع طبعا الجانب البيلاروسي
يرى في ان ارضه مستخدمه للهجوم او تشكيل
اي خطر على الاراضي الاوكرانيه لكن الكثير
من النقاد السياسيين في البلاد يتحدثون عن
ان موسكو قد تلجا لاستخدام الاراضي
البيلاروسيه او الاجواء البيلاروسيه
لتشكيل خطر وهجوم طبعا من الشمال
الاوكراني على كييف او مناطق اخرى مجاوره
لها الوضع على الحدود كما تشاهدين ليال
يعني هي يعني هذا هو الخط الحدودي يعني
يبتعد عني بعض الامطار لكن طبعا المشهد هو
كاحل السواد طبعا يعني
في هذه المنطقه لا لا نعمل الكهرباء هي
موجوده لكن هذه هي منطقه غابات نوعا ما
ليال طبعا لكن الغريب في الموضوع بان هذه
المناطق الحدوديه ليال وهي معروفه بخيرات
ارضها اليوم طبعا لا يوجد عنصر الانسان
فيها طبعا على ما يبدو ان موجات من الهجره
خرجت من هذه المناطق نحو الداخل
البيلاروسي او نحو داخل الروسي والمناطق
المجاوره الاوكرانيه ايضا شهدت نزوحا نحو
المناطق الغربيه لذلك طبعا عنصر يعني
الشباب في هذه المنطقه مختفي نوعا ما طبعا
يقتصر الوضع على بعض السيارات وبعض
المواطنين والقليل من المحال التجاريه
طبعا التي تسير امور الوضع العسكري سكن
عسكريا نلاحظ بان الشريط الحدود الان
يتحول الى سكنه عسكريه لم نلاحظ وجود
لمعدات ثقيله كالدبابات وحاملات يعني
الجنود وغيرها لكن طبعا الوضع قلق نوعا ما
من الحدود البيلاروسيه الاوكرانيه
وبالتالي نحن نتحدث يعني عن شريط حرب لا
نعرف باي دقيقه ممكن ان تبدا شكرا لك عبد
جواد الرشد من الحدود البيلاروسيه
الاوكرانيه على هذه الرساله
[موسيقى]
قالت رئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبيه ان
المفوضيه تناقش مقترح ادراج سبع كيانات
ايرانيه على اثر تزويد الحرس الثوري
الايراني لروسيا بالمسيارات والتي
تستخدمها الاخرى للاعتداء على البنى
التحتيه المدنيه في اوكرانيا
ايوان
الحرس الثوري الايراني يزود روسيا بمثيرات
شاهد حيث تستخدمها في الاعتداءات على
البنى التحتيه المدنيه في اوكرانيا ولذلك
نقترح ادراج سبعه كيانات ايرانيه في قائمه
العقوبات المتصله بالمعدات ذات الاستخدام
المزدوج هذه الكيانات ستخضع لحظر كامل
يمنعها من تصدير مواد دقيقه الى روسيا
ونحن مستعدون لادراج المزيد من كيانات
ايران والدول الاخرى التي تزود روسيا
بالتكنولوجيا الحساسه
من جانبه كشف مسؤول السياسه الخارجيه
الاوروبيه ان مقترح العقوبات الجديده ضد
ايران تفرض حذرا تاما على تصدير اي مكونات
تعود بالفائده على المؤسسات الايرانيه
الصانعه للمسيرات
اقتراح اليوم يفرض حظرا تاما على تصدير اي
مكونات لفائده المؤسسات الايرانيه التي
تصنع المسيرات وقد بحثنا يوم امس في
اجتماع حلف الناتو ادله قاطعه على تزويد
ايران لروسيا بالمسيرات
[موسيقى]
لا يوجد ربط علمي بين حدوث الزلازل
والتغير المناخي ولكن الاخير لا يقل خطوره
عن الزلزال لان المدن الكبرى في العالم
اجمع مهدده بالغرق ومستقبل البشريه ايضا
بسبب ارتفاع مستوى البحار وفق ما كشفته
الامم المتحده فالخطر سيكون كبير لان 900
مليون شخص ممن يعيشون في المناطق الساحليه
حياتهم مهدده بالكامل بعدما ارتفعت درجه
حراره المحيطات العالميه خلال القرن
الماضي بشكل اسرع من اي وقت مضى وفق
التقرير الاممي المنظمه العالميه للارصاد
الجويه تقول لان درجه الحراره العالميه
بلغت
1.5 درجه مئويه مما يساهم بارتفاع كبير في
مستوى سطح البحار
وايضا التقرير حذر من ان درجات الحراره
مرشحه للارتفاع بمقدار درجتين وهذا الامر
سيؤدي الى ارتفاع هائل بمستوى البحار
ويهدد بقاء المناطق الساحليه في العالم
مياه البحار المالحه
ستدمر وستدمر وتتلف البنيه التحتيه
الحيويه في كل المناطق التي ستضربها
المياه كما نشاهد بهذه الصور وستتسبب
بتدمير الوظائف والاقتصادات باكملها في
صناعات رئيسيه مثل الزراعه ومصائد الاسماك
والسياحه المدن الكبرى مشاهدينا في كل
قارات ستواجه تداعيات خطيره بما في ذلك
لاجوس واشنجهاي ولندن ولا انجلوس ونيويورك
وغيرها من الدول والمناطق في جميع انحاء
العالم يؤدي ارتفاع درجات حراره الكوكب
الى ذوبان الانهار والصفائح الجليديه حيث
تفقد القاره القطبيه الجنوبيه ما معدلهم
من كتله الجليد سنويا والغطاء الجليدي في
يذوب ايضا بشكل في جرينلان تحديدا يذوب
بشكل اسرع مما يؤدي الى فقدان 270 مليار
طن سنويا وفق ارقام الامم المتحده
[موسيقى]
قال المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الصينيه ان
الولايات المتحده استخدمت المناطيط كذريعه
لمعاقبه الشركات والمؤسسات الصينيه
الصين شرحت الوضع للولايات المتحده مرارا
وتكرارا لكن الولايات المتحده اساءت
استخدام القوه وبالغت في رد فعلها لتصعيد
الوضع واستخدمت المناطيد كذريعه لمعاقبه
الشركات والمؤسسات الصينيه بشكل غير
قانوني والتي تعارضها الصين بشده وسنتخذ
تدابير مضاده ضد الكيانات الامريكيه ذات
الصله والتي تضر بسياده الصين وامنها
للحفاظ بحزم على السياده الوطنيه
في خبر مرتبط بالصين ايضا حذرت هيئه
رقابيه من ان بريطانيا يجب ان تكون اكثر
قلقا بشان كاميرات المراقبه الصينيه الصنع
في الشوارع من مناطيد التجسس على ارتفاع
60 الف قدم فوق الارض
كاميرات المراقبه الصينيه في شوارع
بريطانيا اخطر من مناطيد التجسس
نتائج البحوث كشفت ان قوات الشرطه مستهدفه
ومراقبه ومخترقه عبر التقنيات الصينيه
اكثر من ثلثي الطائرات المسيره البريطانيه
من صناعه شركه صينيه مدرجه في القائمه
السوداء بالولايات المتحده
السلطات البريطانيه قدرت حجم الخطر الامني
وباتت تبحث عن بدائل للتكنولوجيا الصينيه
استراليا من جهه اخرى قررت ازاله
الكاميرات الامنيه الصينيه من مباني وزاره
الدفاع
ختام التاسعه مشاهدينا مع العنود
الرئيس التركي يرفع عدد الولايات المنكوبه
الى 11
ولايه وفرق الانقاذ توقف البحث عن ناجين
جدد بهطاي حتى
مزيد من المساعدات الامميه الى سوريا
وانفراجا على المعابر الداخليه بين
الاكراد والنظام
[موسيقى]
مع اقتراب الذكرى الاولى لبدء الحرب في
اوكرانيا الناتو يحذر بيلاروسيا من تبعات
التورط الى جانب موسكو
تضييق الخناقه على الحرس الثوريه رئيسه
المفوضيه الاوروبيه تقترح فرض المزيد من
العقوبات على ايران
مشاهدينا التاسعه انتهت لكن اخبار العربيه
مستمره كما كل ليله والان الى 360 مع
الزميلار او ماذا لديك الليل اهلا بك ليال
طبعا سنتحدث عن
الزلزال وبطبيعه الحال وتاثيره على
الانتخابات التركيه في حال اجريت في
موعدها وعن المساعدات الامميه التي بدات
بالوصول الى سوريا في ظل يعني مناطق لم
تصلها ابدا حتى الان تفضل